[Música]
bom dia é um imenso prazer conta que
hoje falando sobre um tema tão
importante para a educação brasileira
a gestão de processos educacionais
tratando das concepções e ações e as
suas interfaces com a suposta qualidade
tratando de inovação algum nem alguns
meses desde que eu fui convidada a estar
aqui eu tenho tentado elaborar uma fala
não tão acadêmica sobre esse tema é mas
eu preciso dizer que é muito difícil
extrapolar
quando se fala de um tema de um assunto
tão complexo
aí comecei a ficar tensa nós vamos lá
então há uns 15 anos eu comecei a focar
um estudo da inovação da e na educação
superior
a minha tese foi na área da pedagogia
universitária e com ela busquei
contribuir com a com a proposição de
modelo de avaliação da educação superior
e apesar de estudar o contexto
brasileiro é eu não fiz essa tese aqui
no brasil porque eu queria buscar um
referencial teórico inovador
eu encontrei no grupo de pesquisa na
universidade de barcelona é e trouxe
referencial teórico para um estudo na
universidade federal do rio grande do
sul
então eu trabalhei com acesso dos
estudantes à educação superior
constatei aí entre outras coisas que no
brasil
dada a natureza patrimonial do estado
ainda muito que fazer e sobre esses
processos
é importante salientar que numa lógica
de disputa pelo mercado educacional
a premissa da inovação se configura como
um forte elemento sobretudo nas
instituições privadas
as estratégias de gestão elas giram em
torno é da busca de soluções frente às
situações consideradas problemáticas
quanto o desempenho dos alunos nas
avaliações
em larga escala como o enade por exemplo
então as instituições buscam atualização
frente ao que vem sendo oferecido por
outras instituições
e digo isso porque hoje o trabalho
renovação pedagógica na prática fazendo
esses processos de gestão acontecerem e
aí mas o que é inovação é a inovação é
somente relacionado até está somente
relacionada à tecnologia
não há inovação é também está em outros
meios a inovação está no planejamento em
um planejamento que atenda às diferentes
demandas da sociedade dos estudantes
acontece que atualmente nós constatamos
que a solução da própria casa
sedução das promessas de poder emprego
aos que melhor desenvolverem suas
funções intelectuais superiores
ela serve de base à proposta que
fundamentam a qualidade da educação
e aí a idéia da adoção de um único
modelo educativo para todos os alunos
essa premissa se respalda no modelo da
educação por competências é um termo que
foi definido pelo antropólogos
sociólogos philippe perrenoud em 1999
foi definido como a capacidade de agir
eficazmente mundo em uma determinada
situação apoiado em conhecimentos mas
sem se limitar a esses conhecimentos e
aí com apogeu do processo de
globalização econômica e
conseqüentemente a permanente mudança no
decurso do desenvolvimento social e
pessoal que resulta da expansão do
capitalismo e das profundas modificações
nas sociedades contemporâneas com a
imposição de novos desafios
a tendência a trabalhar mais
intelectualmente com autonomia e
capacidade criativa
assim o que se exige dessa sociedade não
está somente nos livros na internet e
nas técnicas nós fundamentalmente no
indivíduo que deve incorporar essa
transformação essas transformações aos
seus valores
então não é novidade que os indivíduos
mais escolarizadas têm melhor inserção
no mercado de trabalho e que tendem a
lugar maiores rendimentos financeiros
então a formação superior
ela atualmente as caracteriza por exigir
maior empenho dos alunos no seu próprio
processo formativo e aí na complexidade
do problema a ser enfrentado na
organização institucional e curricular
para melhora para acolher o maior número
de estudantes ao mesmo tempo promover a
atualização programática requerida pelos
novos tempos da ciência da cultura do
desenvolvimento social e econômico do
brasil está com uma questão como
reconhecer a diferente ou é insuficiente
preparação acadêmica da nova geração
universitária e trazer essa situação ao
planejamento institucional didático
pedagógico de modo contribuir para o
outro processo formativo e evitar o
abandono dos estudos e consequentemente
o desperdício dos recursos públicos e
privados com educação superior
bom nessa linha a ampliação do acesso ea
permanência são dimensões dos processos
de gestão e requerem inovação sobre o
acesso à educação superior à meta 12 do
plano nacional de educação pne é prevê
elevação da taxa líquida de matrículas
na educação superior para 33% da
população de 18 a 24 anos assegurando a
qualidade na oferta e na expansão
o destaque do acesso à educação superior
está relacionado à problemática da
permanência evasão
assim além da garantia do acesso às
políticas educacionais devem garantir a
permanência ea educação de qualidade e
para isso acontecer é preciso um forte
investimento na educação desde o nível
básico mas carlos estudantes
eu preciso dizer que o acesso à educação
superior
ele não leve ser considerado um
privilégio
segundo a capacidade de cada um ao
contrário deve ser considerado um
direito democrático a todo cidadão pois
uma democracia efetiva só pode acontecer
em uma sociedade de quem é emancipada e
o fator quantitativo número de
ingressantes não é suficiente para que
ocorra a democratização da educação a
necessidade existe uma necessidade que
haja permanência do estudante obviamente
e qualidade no processo formativo dessa
maneira e dessa maneira as políticas
para o ensino superior elas devem
traduzir os compromissos de mudanças
necessárias aos tempos atuais mudanças
alicerçados na democracia e na autonomia
plena
segundo os dados e trazendo um pouco de
dados do censo da educação superior de
2010 16 é temos no brasil hoje 2.407
instituições de educação superior
espalhadas pelo país
dessas 88% são privadas
apesar do número de instituições o
brasil ainda apresenta um percentual
relativamente baixo de jovens da faixa
etária de 18 a 24 anos cursando a
educação superior
quero dizer que 83% do total da
população nessa faixa etária estão
excluídos da educação superior
bem
assim sendo a opção por políticas que
buscam atender aos grupos sociais
historicamente historicamente não
tiveram acesso à educação superior
vencendo uma medida inovadora e de
fundamental importância por se
constituir e uma possibilidade de
contribuir com a diminuição das
desigualdades sociais
mas além dessas ações se faz necessário
uma política social que atenda às
necessidades da população e
especificamente uma política educacional
que prioriza a educação em sua
totalidade básica e superior
e eu destaco aqui a falta a ausência de
um sistema nacional de educação ea
qualidade dessa educação também inovação
para sinalizar se uma instituição
educacional tem qualidade
a primeira questão que se coloca é a que
conceitos representações ou concepções
de qualidade deve embasar as práticas as
políticas educativas
as dimensões e os fatores que apóiam
essa construção que almejamos
eu tenho analisado os projetos
pedagógicos institucionais de algumas
universidades e eu observo que a análise
de limitação do perfil do egresso é
frequente encontrar a preocupação
informar cidadãos críticos e éticos
capazes de contribuir para o
desenvolvimento humano para o bem estar
da sociedade e aptos a exercer
profissões atuais e futuras porque as
universidades elas são depositárias é
das esperanças sociais de grande parte
da população que espera e cobra
resultados e benefícios sociais e
culturais efetivos dessas instituições
de educação superior
pra pra isso as instituições precisam
limitar planejamentos de acompanhamento
os ingressantes e graça bem então é
chegando aqui o fechamento da minha fala
eu quero retomar a relação entre
qualidade inovação com um meio para a re
construção da universidade e reforça que
a inovação na educação superior deve ser
também nos processos deve estar também
focada nos processos de gestão no
planejamento acadêmico de modo a
assegurar o acesso à manutenção do
estudante no sistema e garantir a
qualidade social e desde a minha
percepção à educação superior vai ter
qualidade na medida que ela for capaz de
garantir o desenvolvimento de estudantes
visto as demandas do mundo globalizado e
conectado e plural de incorporar e
fomentar a tecnologia suas dimensões e
os seus desdobramentos de perceber e
inovação como princípio articulador e
propulsor do conhecimento afrontar a
avaliação para a melhoria do processo
educativo e de reorientar os currículos
e modelos educacionais para o
desenvolvimento do pensamento crítico
finalmente como coloquei antes na gestão
dos processos educacionais existem
muitas dimensões a serem trabalhadas e
eu destaquei aqui o acesso a permanência
ea qualidade social como produtos do
planejamento que direcione os esforços
da inovação e pra terminar eu faço a
vocês um convite vamos analisar e
pesquisar mais sobre esses processos
o brasil precisa consagrar uma educação
democrática e de qualidade social para
garantir o desenvolvimento dessa
sociedade historicamente marcada pela
desigualdade e pela discriminação
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]